maman je crois que je sais qu' a ta
fille
cette fille sort d'une secte tu crois
vraiment qu'on peut lui faire confiance
on
aemou les autoritésetrou ta fille si tu
veux la récupérer tu devras le faire
toiême où est ma fille elle était en vie
y de
semaines je l'ai véc si elle est viante
luiont subirenf fois pire que ce que les
gens
imaginent
on y vaavais pas parlé de tatouage
imagine 2 secondes que je rentre dans
une de tes églises avec
cette c'est pas une bonne idée de nous
suivre
respect il amè des enfants ici à la fin
il
parfo on va envoyer à Cyrus un
message tu as envie de mourir où est ma
fille où est ma
fille tu vas passer de l'autre
côté fais gaffe mec j'ai goûté au S
dernièrement et je suis pas sûr d'avoir
l'estomac plein papa tu
l'ai tu l'
tous je suis libre je suis l'univers
tiens regarde voilà le vrai
[Musique]
Dieu